um so
um to start
is Andrew Tate guilty or innocent
uh I personally think there's enough out
there that Andrew Tate himself has said
that unless he's lying about what he's
done he's obviously guilty of at least a
few things uh namely defrauding the
women that he gets to work for him
probably trafficking via the Loverboy
method
um but I don't think anybody should be
convicted of a crime unless adequate
evidence is brought forth in a fair
court and then he's had his day to
defend himself so I think he's probably
guilty but I think we should wait and
see how the process plays out okay and
what is your take yeah matek is looking
at the evidence and looking at the data
that we have in front of us I don't
believe he's guilty and that's all we
can base it on is the evidence that's
supposed to snippets on YouTube or
things that have been phrased or
portrayed in a certain way VIA social
media
so Destiny you mentioned the Loverboy
method do you think that the Loverboy
method is actually sex trafficking and
why
um I don't have thoughts on it or it's
not like my goal is to Define like what
is sex trafficking I just go by what the
laws are and usually the questions are
is he guilty of the crime of sex
trafficking and the lover boy method is
defined as sex driving I believe in most
countries because at least in Romania
and I think in most countries if you are
able to get a girl to do sex work using
a coercive or fraudulent method meaning
you're Miss uh you're misleading them as
to what your relationship is then that
would constitute sex trafficking if you
exploit them afterwards for sex work
okay what about you yeah I agree with
what Destiny said just towards the end
so basically Loverboy method is a method
by which human trafficking occurs so if
someone did human sorry if someone did
Loverboy method on its own
that would not be a crime so what makes
it a crime is when you do the Loverboy
method and then you meet the
requirements of human trafficking and
therefore you then meet the standard so
on its own lower body method a person
would not be convicted of human
trafficking solely based on Loverboy
method so where do you guys disagree
then
I mean I think you're kind of on the
same page I mean I actually don't know
what Destiny's position is so I'd
actually like Yeah well my position is
we should wait and see what the court
system does I think everything they've
done up to this point has been A-Okay
seems to be by the books um and then I
should I think we should wait and see
how the process plays out I believe
there's uh in Romanian law up to a
maximum of 180 days so they can remain
detained while they finish their
investigation and then it's up to the
Romanian Court to decide whether or not
they want to bring charges to the Tates
right so in terms of what what uh
Destiny said I don't think that they've
done everything A-Okay that's the first
point and the second point is I do
believe that they've contravened certain
um domestic as well as International
laws and then separate to that when it
um and separate of that evens when you
look at the
um reminding someone for 180 days
although that doesn't contravene law I
have serious issues with that as well
could you wait could you see the second
part of that again yeah so so the 180
days although that is within Romanian
law I have serious issues issues with it
and I can expand on that few hours okay
yeah could you tell me why yeah of
course so basically we have a scenario
where in Romania you have you can
basically detain someone without having
adequate evidence to prosecute or
convict so essentially you detain
someone take away the liberty and rights
put them in prison and then say guess
what I'm looking for evidence now I
understand a lot of people may not
understand the problems with this but
coming from the background that I am
being a Muslim being an Asian most a lot
of our community have been through this
both in the United States and the United
Kingdom when your Liberty is taken away
without due process without having a
trial without evidence being submitted
and so for us from the perspective of
minorities and perspective from that
perspective we have serious issues
because that was used to terrorize our
community for more than 120 years so yes
I will speak out about that even if it's
in the United States the United Kingdom
Romania France I think it's a serious
issue when you could take away someone's
Liberty without having adequate evidence
and six months is horrendous to take
away someone's Liberty that's a
significant period of someone's life to
say we haven't got enough evidence we're
going to jail you for six months and
then we're gonna look for the evidence
do you agree with him or no
um I would if what he was saying was
true so okay
um I feel like there's a lot of tricky
word games being played when we talk
about detaining somebody without enough
evidence so in the Romanian legal system
if you are in the finishing stages of an
investigation you can detain somebody
while you finish that investigation up
especially if you believe the people
you're detaining might be a Flight Risk
you can detain somebody without having
enough evidence to charge them with a
crime or convict them of a crime
obviously but you do require compelling
evidence to detain somebody which is
left to the discretion of the judges
that are willing on the case I've
noticed that you've quoted that document
sometimes the one that was released in
it was either November or December where
the judge said that there's not enough
evidence to convict of a crime you've
said that several times but they're not
looking for enough evidence to convict
them of a crime what the judge was
supposed to evaluate was is there enough
evidence to Warrant detaining them and
he did feel like there was enough
evidence at that time and the statements
that he's made and the Romanian criminal
code are all completely okay with the UN
and with the United States and with any
other International legal body so I
don't understand when we try to push
against the Romanian legal system why we
say things like it's against
international law or it's against
International freedoms when this is how
the Romanian criminal court system has
been structured it's one of the reasons
why Andrew Tate you know verbally said
he was going to move there I don't agree
that it's in violation of any
International laws if it is I'd like to
hear which ones
your first point about
um in terms of the level of evidence
that was required to remind him so my
position is that it's unacceptable to
remind someone when you haven't got
enough evidence to prosecute or to
convict the threshold to hold someone
isn't isn't the way you framed it where
it's very close to basically prosecute
or convict the evidence is based on
Reasonable Suspicion so the bar is very
low to meet that threshold hence why I
have a problem with it if the bar was
much higher it was close to Beyond
reasonable doubt maybe even if it was um
balance a probability we could maybe
talk about that and look at the
possibility of why that would be
acceptable but when the balance is
reasonable suspicion the bar is very low
it's easy to me and that's why I think
so unacceptable first point second point
in terms of where they've contributed
international law that's a separate
issue so I will go into that because I
know you've asked a fair question so
I'll just I'll just go through it so
first of all Article Five one of the
European European commission which is a
corporate intermedia law so it breaks
European law as well as
um domestic Romanian law states that
whenever you provide evidence or
prosecution provides evidence he has to
provide evidence both for and against
his stance that's not happened he has
not included evidence which is for
example the CCTV evidence he has not
included for example evidence which is
um long-form text messages which include
the entirety of the conversation he's
not included the witness statements
three of the women's statements of the
alleged victims who say they're not
victims so those are examples of
contributing Article Five One they've
convened article 9 2 which this one we
can argue because uh the first one I
don't think there'll be much argument
but second one nine two is you can only
detain on exceptional circumstances and
then nine four is that basically it's
illegal to detain someone unless the
circumstances are exceptional and in
this case the exceptionality or the
illegality or the problematic issue was
that basically the psych report was used
as a basis to detain them and the psych
report has significant issues in it and
I can go into depth in that if you want
would you like me to actually move on
well for the I guess for the first point
that you bring up
we should get a notepad to write down on
a notepad yeah unironically for the
first part that you bring up um so
saying that you need Beyond a probable
um Beyond probable doubt
um I'm sorry reasonable or Beyond
Reasonable Doubt no no no sorry yeah
Reasonable Suspicion okay Reasonable
Suspicion
um I think it's maybe fair to take issue
with these things but I mean different
courts across different countries are
allowed to set up their legal systems in
the ways that they see fit and the
Romanian courts are set up in a way that
is in accordance with the European
commission um the judge himself
references the EC and provides
um the evidence that they have for the
EC in the statement that he released in
order to make sure that it was on the up
and up
um I I it's I understand that the desire
to critique the Romanian legal system I
wouldn't want to live in a system like
that personally but that's why I moved
to the United I live in the United
States I haven't moved to another
country to participate in that legal
system you have the picture
Patriot Act in the United States as well
we have the similar Provisions we might
have sure we might but I'm just saying
that Andrew Tate the Tates specifically
moved to Romania because they said they
wanted to specifically take advantage of
that legal system there are videos of
Tate saying lock me up in jail I'll give
them a thousand dollars and I'll be out
and I'll have a musus and blah blah blah
and he's saying that and he moved to
that system and that system is legal
insofar as the EU framework is concerned
because nobody's challenged it nobody
has said anything about it and I think
that to try to call out that particular
way of doing things now I think Rings a
little bit Hollow uh okay I'll answer
that and then we can move on to the
Article Five Point so in terms of the
reason of Suspicion yeah again I have a
huge problem with it irrespective of
Andrew Taylor he was in a situation
where he there was lenience in the in
leniency in the law that was error on
his part but it doesn't mean that just
because someone makes a silly decision
and assumes that certain laws you know
this that is unaware of the the
legalistic system in a certain country
that he should then the harshness of it
we should ignore as well in terms of the
harshness of it the reason why we have
severe issues is because it's I can
understand why you may not understand it
but people from the minority Community
who have been abused and terrorized by
these laws they understand what the
problem is by it and so for all of it
for us we're not just hating on the
Romanian system we're saying anywhere in
the world that has detention without
having a significant amount of evidence
where you know you can prosecute or
convict is something that we will speak
out about and it's wrong so it's not
just the Romanian system I said Germania
us UK France whichever country whichever
country is detaining people with only
based on minimal level of evidence which
is reasonable suspicion is completely
inappropriate unacceptable and we will
speak out against the irrespective of
who's being detained and so we have that
in Cortana mobile and significant
amounts of people from the United from
the Muslim Community who are being
detained without due process based on
Reasonable Suspicion and have never been
to trial do you think that Guantanamo
Bay a military prison setup outside of
the United States in order to maintain
like foreign prisoners or terrorists
like people without uniforms do you
think that's comparable to what's
happening right now in the Romanian
criminal court system and so you make a
fair point because of it's not
comparable in the time in the sense of
the timeline because some of them have
spent 20 years yeah but it's comparable
in the sense of the aspect of and so I'd
give that as an extreme example so
that's an example but also people get
detained for like 14 days 28 days three
months six months nine months without it
without without it all of that is
unacceptable so okay when you say
unacceptable you mean to you it's not
violating any international law you just
personally don't like it yeah yeah yeah
no no well when I say I personally don't
like it I think it's something that as a
someone who's a member of the community
of the world irrespective of what it is
and because you don't experience it you
probably don't realize but it's a major
issue for all of us and it has been for
20 years that's fine but we haven't been
talking about it for 20 years we've been
talking about it for the past three
months really with the undertaking well
we've been talking about it for 20 years
sure I'm sure some people have yeah if
if you want to have a personal issue
with how some people do detainments
without I guess uh meeting a certain
threshold of you know publicly available
evidence I think that's an interesting
conversation to have but I'm pretty sure
that this particular thing has to do
with the Andrew take case and these
particular opinions have to do with
opinions about the legal system not
whether or not it's actually violating
international law so yeah I I don't like
the framing of I don't think this is
fair therefore it violates statements or
uh guidelines by the European commission
violated right yeah that wasn't my point
so okay because because you're
completing my two points so my point was
about Reasonable Suspicion specifically
why I have a problem with it very clear
that that did not break international
law actually said it I said it it didn't
my proof of why it breaks international
law outside Article 5 and I'm going to
cite another five six more legislations
what he breaks and that hasn't got to do
a reasonable suspicion that's got to do
with uh evidence
okay
um so the first one was the first one
was Article Five one which says that
basically the prosecution has a duty to
provide so for example in the United
Kingdom in the United States what
happens is the prosecutor gains the
information he and and this is the same
in Romania what should be according to
Article Five one as well as a condition
national law what the prosecutor does is
he gets information he looks like look
this is the strong point for my case but
actually these are the weak points
because this proves the defendant's case
I'm going to clear all of that and give
it to the pro give it to the prosecutor
so this in this case says dicot and then
the prosecutor then makes a decision
based on both of the evidence and
decides wait a sec the evidence isn't
strong enough because our case is weak
at this point I'm not going to take this
forward to prosecute and so in the
United Kingdom the prosecutor is called
the CPS
I'm saying this where he's contravened
international law article 5-1 is he did
not provide the evidence that it weakens
his own case to be able to prosecute so
that was my first point so you're saying
they didn't give them as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible